Michael Wilbon back here on the show how
are you Michael rich I'm tired and I
have no voice but other than that I'm
good okay so let's start with the let's
start with the the yelling and the
screaming that went down last night in
Oakland what what do you take away from
the five-game Warriors victory Michael I
didn't know going into the series that
they were what I'd call a superior team
I thought they were ever so slightly
better and that would have been because
of Durant what I didn't know is that it
would turn out to their superior because
of Durant because draymond Green was in
the game and because steph curry was
healthier than he was last year and you
know there there's the phrase super team
does fit and now in much the same way
that it happened in the 60s with the
Celtics and the way it happened you know
it was into the seventies with them too
and then it all changed around a lot in
the seventies but the way it happened in
the 80s with magics Lakers no way it
happened in nice with Michaels Bulls um
everybody else has to try to do
something about this but I don't know
how willing the teams are to really
commit I think this is interesting a lot
of people talk about all this we're
loaded up to three or four years from
now because nothing lasts a river which
is true by the way I mean I know people
out there saying oh the runners could do
this for the next six or seven years I
don't believe that at all
I believe that sports now particularly
in the age of Sally Captain free agency
you could do something for a few years I
don't think you can do it for six or
eight years anymore um till the Patriots
have been able to a remarkable thing I
don't know in pro basketball where
there's movement and where one person
disproportionately impacts the outcome
of something I don't think you can
sustain it but for right now man um
they're a super team and there's nobody
who can beat them in it and I want to
see which wish franchises are interested
in actually trying to us to try to win
who wants to try to beat them and who's
going to put a planet well in that
Michael I mean you know obviously the
Cavs would be have to be the
to try because you've got LeBron and
you've got I'm still in that window
where he is a superlative player based
on the numbers that we saw despite the
the finals lost the question is what
what does that mean it's not like to use
the NFL way of doing things you can't
build through the draft because you're
not going to take some 18 19 year-old
kid and stick him with LeBron unless
he's Magic Johnson and I and put out
there so so what what is the way to
building to try and compete with the
Golden State Warriors right now I don't
think I don't think Cleveland I I mean I
wake up this morning thinking something
completely different Cleveland they got
some major questions first of all who's
going to build David Griffin who gives
no credit as general manager is a
superior general manager and he's been a
great executive for multiple teams so
he's a free agent he may leave so who
would even be doing it that we got to
start there arm is the owner willing to
pay that much more into the luxury tax
for a year not knowing what LeBron is
going to do I mean they signed LeBron to
an extension I guess I don't know all
the new rules off top of my head but I
we do we really think the balls going to
do that with Cleveland or what would
Cleveland be willing to do how
dramatically they are dramatic amuses
they want to make wanna trade Kyrie
Irving for Chris Paul or try to I'll
because if you're LeBron you're not
worried about what's going to happen
because you're training up in years and
what's going to happen is Kyrie is only
24 he's got more time about any time he
needs to win now so whether than when
the Cavaliers doctor moves
you know we Chris Paul be interested in
coming to play with LeBron James in
Cleveland instead of letting LeBron Nick
lovingly toward Los Angeles after next
you know this time next year so a big
part of this is what is Cleveland want
to do what are they committed to I'm not
going to say you've been in the final
three times in one one and that's that I
mean all these things are on the table
remember they got free agents support
players Korver Deron Williams they got
guys with opt outs Kyrie is one of them
in a year LeBron obviously has one I'm
missing somebody maybe love well well
would not be really Michael Wilbon here
on the show would not technically be
LeBron skal
okay our if they're if three is enough
if you will three three Finals
appearances is enough and you know I
looked at the Cavs and I didn't sit
there and think that Kyrie was a problem
I mean in he's not the solution nakai
really attacking just to watch as a fan
he is it spectacular but I watch the
finals several games of it sitting with
the following people
Paul Pierce can't been headed to the
Hall of Fame child he blows champion
it's certainly going to get Hall of Fame
strong consideration and genuine Rose
was played in huge games and the finals
in the Conference Finals and they were
often exasperated from a team standpoint
that's what it is that doesn't happen
when Kyrie scores like that if I
watching Game of Magic Johnson and you
sitting there and he's looking at
something else totally different from
the wonder of finishing at the rim which
Kyrie Irving can do as well as anyone
who has ever played it's spectacular but
when LeBron James says in the month of
March he needs a playmaker what should
that have told us didn't have another
one on the team and they couldn't win
gold if they have five of them guys you
can all get eight or ten assists on a
given night they don't do it every night
that they can that's not what he does
that's what Chris Paul does Chris Paul
is a superior playmaker still wanted to
interview best in the league so so what
do we again what are we talking about in
terms of commitment idiot LeBron is
called the brown line of state why would
with Cleveland to the commission of
LeBron James says the danglars you know
I'm really thinking about this la thing
when I'm building this twenty million
dollar house what's this thing good
we're going to say he wants to have a
lot with a bunch of other guys and pay
into the luxury tax I mean there's a lot
to be determined want to be determining
we LeBron said last night listen to his
first quote I got a sitting out for a
while and figure this thing out
that's what he said because of the
nation post game first thought he took a
deep breath because somebody said
basically they asked him sort of that
question not as explained anot as direct
and that's what he said
and that you we saw for a moment that
but Brown has just turned over to say my
god a lot just happened I just lost the
final series and which I averaged too
low a triple freakin double nobody's
done it no one's done it here was a
triple double and they couldn't win they
couldn't get close to winning the series
so Michael when it all comes down to it
you know are if if LeBron best player is
saying that from the team that had the
best shot of knocking off the Warriors
and or has and then you've got the Spurs
team with the best shot of doing it with
in conference being in flux with you
know Parker seemingly done and Ginobili
and you know collide obvious all this
all right so the question is is our poll
question today is the Warriors winning
good for the NBA yes or no how do you
respond yes yes yes yes that's not even
an issue when is the dynasty or a great
great great great team than bad for the
NBA the Indians built on that its
foundation on its foundation or it's
very foundation are the Celtics and Bill
Russell ten or eleven of them whatever
it is and Magic Johnson going to finals
nine times in 12 years yes this is what
the NBA is is not a debate the NBA is
dynastic teams popping up every decade
or so and bringing people into the tent
that way this is not you know that's why
the notion of I was arguing my dear
friend Steven Smith Steven Smith that's
why the notion of of Kevin Durant
destroying parity different parity this
isn't the NFL there's no parity this is
a Pete Rozelle lead this is a league
that has dynasties only five teams I'm
exaggerating even one championships
we don't spread it around this isn't any
given Sunday this is a league in which
dominant players come in and for ten
years you go and buy tickets to see them
like it's the theater bill Russell's
come into town wilt is coming to town
the former GM and president of the
Washington Bullets Wizard season
O'Malley
she
was sold a package with the Wizards
bullets were no good she sold the
package that said come and see the Dream
Team this isn't this is right after the
summer 92 and in that package of tickets
for Washington DC fans
you came to see Malone in Stockton
Jordan and Pippen David Robinson Drexler
you came in you saw the dream team
players this is not the individual great
players and dynastic teams are necessary
to the health of the NBA and so when I
hear people saying this is bad for the
NBA no there's stupidly naive this is
this is not even debatable this is the
way that league functions and partners
itself with networks and sells tickets
it's like the upset for March Madness or
any given Sunday parody that goes on for
years and years to the NFL it's the
secret to its success and the people
aren't seeing it left and now we get to
find out who is interested in trying for
real to beat the Warriors the Spurs will
try for real
but they'll grab three people you never
heard of at the end of the first round
at an early second round and two and
will be Hall of Famers because that's
what they do and they're not stirred
well I hope that cheap about it I hope
they're right and I'm not trolling here
Michael I love what you just said and
and the problem is is that some of these
players that you want to go see don't
play because they're resting because if
an issue and that's I greet rich you are
a hundred percent right that's a problem
not the Warriors and whether they win
too much nobody thought there was a
problem Michael Jordan the Bulls are
winning state was 1769 back-to-back
which is more I'm not a math majors and
the Warriors won back-to-back these last
few years because key championships the
problem is you have to be able to trust
the money you spend in the ticket is
going to get you into the theater to not
see the understudy but to see the lead
that's the problem and but what you are
100% right about well and in terms just
to wrap this up but when Jordan was
winning those those games in the regular
season they were still some some finals
and also some playoff series of
where you felt like the Knicks or Reggie
Miller could pull it off or you felt
like Karl Malone might have a shot or or
Drexler and the Blazers might have a
shot you still felt like you had a shot
like this just didn't feel that way I'm
just well this is a feeling because
Kawhi Leonard got hurt you feel he had a
shot at 25 points up and I in an Oracle
I did I mean so yeah they were going to
win that game that game is over
if he doesn't encounter Zaza Pachulia
size 28 foot then that's a 1o lead and I
think the San Antonio can get another
game in San Antonio at least yeah so
that was weird the ball Villa the Bulls
ran through the bull championships up
there was a competitive remember rich
they were up three Oh after beating
Seattle by like 25 in Seattle in the
finals Payton and kill right and then
they just saw it got disinterested and
they dropped the problem back home and
finished it but there were times where
yeah the Knicks and the Pacers provided
some real great series they did and and
it's better when it league has five or
sixteen six or seven teams that can
threaten not three this year it was four
you had three in the West and you had or
so you thought in that change and you
had Cleveland that's all you really had
because Boston and Washington went real
viable dress yet so yes three is two
feet Michael it's never more than six or
seven in history league
Michael love your perspective say hi to
Tony travel safe get that voice back and
I look forward to our next chat already
thanks I got to get it back cycle scream
to tell you love it tell them I said hi
fake that you got associated it's my
club on the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to